bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end votre magazine id et sorties
pour le week-end nous parlerons des
septièmes rencontres théâtrales de but
que durant deux week-ends la commune met
à l'honneur le théâtre et
particulièrement la comédie les
rencontres débutent ce vendredi 29
janvier la ferme du manet accueille la
deuxième édition du concert symphonique
du conservatoire de montigny le
bretonneux
la première partie verra jouer les
élèves du conservatoire avant de laisser
place à l' orchestre symphonique
mais tout d'abord on part à lille de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
mais plus présent précisément son centre
équestre
ce dimanche plus de 300 cavaliers s'y
donnent rendez vous avec au programme
concours de saut d'obstacles et de
hunter pour en parler sandra buron
bonjour je vous êtes la responsable du
centre
vous en êtes où dans votre préparation à
veiller encore des équipes les équipes
s'affairent encore à la préparation du
concours
voilà comme on a les cours aussi au
quotidien on peut pas bloquer les
installations uniquement pour le
concours donc c'est encore en cours
jusqu'à demain soir et le dimanche matin
on sera encore dessus jusqu'au dernier
moment alors compétition de saut
d'obstacles et de hunter qu'est ce que
c'est alors le saut d'obstacles c'est un
enchaînement de
deux parcours face est un enchaînement
da sur un parcours d'obstacles donc il
ya tout un tracé à suivre que les
cavaliers découvre le jour de la
compétition et le but c'est d'aller le
plus vite possible sans faire tomber
deux barres d'obstacles c'est très
technique c'est technique parce qu'il
faut bien repéré son tracé au départ
faut le mémoriser donc très rapidement
puisque on a à peu près une demi heure
avant d' avant de passer d'aller
s'échauffer et puis après l'idée c'est
de réussir à prendre des options qui
vont permettre de pouvoir aller le plus
vite possible et donc de gagner quelques
quelques secondes et le hunter alors le
hunter c'est aussi un enchaînement
d'obstacles par contre là il n'y a pas
du tout de chronomètre en jeu tout est
noté sur la qualité du cavalier sa
position le style du cheval la
préparation la qualité des allures donc
là on est plus d'un côté dans celui qui
va le plus vite qu'ils gagnent et de
l'autre côté dans celui qui monte le
mieux qui va gagner
voilà c'est une question de prestance
lanter hausse et de prestations oui oui
aussi c'est on a souvent tendance à dire
que c'est un mélange entre le dressage
est l'obstacle voilà sa demande d'avoir
un cheval qui qui soit dressé un petit
peu différemment et là donc ça ça
receuil un petit peu moins de monde sur
voilà pour donner une idée sur les 345
qu'on attend dimanche il y en a que 45
ans enter et 300 sur le saut d'obstacles
345 c'est un gros événement pour le
centre équestre
c'est un très gros événement puisque moi
ça fait quand même
maintenant 12 ans que je gère le centre
équestre et on n'avait jamais atteint
ces chiffres là donc c'est bien
évidemment grâce à tous les travaux qui
ont été effectués au centre équestre
depuis deux ans qui nous ont permis
d'avoir de très belles installations qui
donne donc envie aux cavaliers de
devenir participer au concours dans
notre club plutôt que d'aller dans un
autre club ce dimanche
c'est une compétition de loisirs où il
ya un objectif
alors il ya un petit peu de tout il ya
différents niveaux d'épreuves qui
permettent d'être à la fois pour du
loisir est à la fois ce sont des manches
qualificatives pour les championnats de
france clubs qui auront lieu au mois de
juillet en sologne et un beau but quand
même bien beau but web est tout à fait
ça fait partie des épreuves
qualificatives
pourquoi le centre a choisi d'accueillir
une telle compétition finalement ben
justement comme je le disais par rapport
à cette opportunité d'avoir des
installations qui le permettent
donc on a décidé d'organiser ce concours
là on a à peu près une 15 20 dates dans
l'année de compétition donc là bas c'est
un un petit peu tôt puisqu'on est encore
en hiver mais bon on a de la chance
d'avoir un hiver doux donc qui a quand
même permis de faire venir les cavaliers
et parmi ces cavaliers y aura des saint
quentinois alors des saint quentinois
oui il y en a quand même beaucoup nous
dans nos adhérents ça représente à peu
près 75 tours qui vont voilà à peu près
une 30 35 40 cavaliers qui vont faire 75
participations
et dans ceux là il ya des cavaliers qui
vise effectivement les championnats de
france surtout à poney certains
pourraient aller loin c'est peut-être un
peu tôt pour le dire sur les
championnats de france club à celle
vivier pour ceux qui iront plus loin
après pour l'instant c'est un petit peu
tôt pour le dire mais en concours
complet on a eu régulièrement des
champions de france où cette année en
2015 on a eu un vice champion de france
donc voilà c'est on doit démarrer par ça
en tout cas et à destination du public
c'est pour les amateurs ou des gens
qu'il faut qu' il faut s'y connaître
pour suivre une telle compétition
non là du saut d'obstacles du coût et du
hunter c'est vraiment ouvert à tout le
monde même si on ne s'y connaît pas il
ya vraiment un intérêt il ya une
ambiance on comprend tout de suite la
règle du jeu on va dire donc on voit
celui qui va aller le plus vite qui va
tourner plus court qui va pas faire de
tomber d'obstacles donc c'est vraiment
ouvert au grand public jeudi qui est
très agréable à regarder
oui tout à fait aux essais dynamiques et
voilà l accès libre l'accès est libre ou
8 août a fait s'acquitter de l'entrée de
la base de loisirs mais après ça sur le
site du centre équestre l'accès est
libre il ya possibilité de devenir entre
8h30 et 17h 30 les épreuves se
dérouleront sur ce créneau horaire là
même si les cavaliers viano sur
l'échauffement un peu avant mais à
partir de 8h30 il commencera à y avoir
du spectacle
merci sont environ des venu nous
présenter cette épreuve pour découvrir
cette compétition équestre et supporter
les concurrents direction le centre
équestre de l'île de loisirs c'est de 8
heures à 18 heures on reste dans le
sport avec la 81e édition de paris
mantes
quatre parcours nocturne avec notamment
pour les plus valeureux un circuit de 54
km au départ de versailles on écoute
patrick challans et c'est l'organisateur
de cette édition
il était l'invitée jeudi soir de
florennes parfait et nickel et mido
toutes les familles des marcheurs sont
l'un au bord de la route avec des
ravitaillements privé parce que nous
avons nous sur le seul sur le parcours
trois ravitaillements
ou les les marcheurs peuvent se
ravitailler et de la soupe du café
des gâteaux des fruits secs ou tout est
mis en oeuvre pour que la la marche se
déroule très bien de toute la nuit et
les les marcheurs sont applaudis et
surtout à l'arrivée tout le monde les
attend avec une haie d'honneur
une envie de lecture ce week-end avec
vos enfants laurent garin du pavé du
canal de montigny le bretonneux vous
propose de découvrir cité babel de
pascal et de leurs égales duhaze un
ouvrage ludique accessible dès l'âge de
6 ans et qui propose un tour d'horizon
des religions au lait coûte aujourd'hui
je vous présente cité babel le grand
livre des religions qu'un documentaire
jeunesse de pascal et de l'ain et gaëlle
du hazé alors c'est un documentaire un
peu particulier qui est découpé en
quatre 4 parties et en fait tout se
décline dans le livre donc en fait on va
suivre les trois grandes religions
monothéistes donc au départ ont donc on
va voir ici l'islam le judaïsme le
catholicisme ici et en bas on va avoir
une personne apte et est donc comment
vivre dans cet immeuble l'a donc en fait
le documentaire est déclinée sur les
trois étages de l'immeuble
comment cohabitent ces familles et
quelles sont les différentes fêtes
religieuses qu'elles sont des
différentes coutumes les habitudes
religieuses de chacun et chacune et
comment tout le monde arrive à vivre
ensemble dans cet immeuble est donc la
famille du balat qui est la commerçante
elle voit un peu passé toutes ces
religions là et toutes ces personnes qui
sont aussi
2 enfin qui voit aussi des personnes
polythéistes enfin voila c'est un peu le
maillon est le point central de
l'immeuble sur les trois religions qu'on
voit là ce qui est vraiment très
intéressant dans ce documentaire c'est
quand on suit vraiment toutes ces
familles là tout au long de l'année et
tous les liens qui peuvent avoir entre
ces trois familles là et voilà cette
présentation la en spirale des trois
étages c'est une façon très iconoclaste
s'en va dire enfin très particulière de
te présenter ça à l'enfant et donc il ya
souvent faim il ya systématiquement un
petit texte qui vient expliquer le
contexte de la cérémonie et comment la
famille décline star lui aujourd'hui
dans sa vie de tous les jours et donc la
toute dernière famille qu'est la famille
commerçante elle voit donc passer des
gens qui sont plus polythéistes et donc
on raconte aussi enfin donc on décrit un
peu la vie des personnes donc d'autres
religions
on poursuit cette chute week-end avec de
nouvelles idées sorties de ce soir la
vie de bus clan ces rencontres
théâtrales où la comédie est à l'honneur
cette année et c'est jean-marc le
rudulier le maire de la commune qui va
nous en parler bonjour bonsoir
alors si rendez vous autour du théâtre à
destination de tous les publics
c'est une volonté de la commune c'est
une volonté de la commune que développer
effectivement le théâtre pour tout le
monde à des prix très compétitifs
puisque on est à des prix relativement
bas puisque je crois que l'entrée c'est
aux alentours de 8 lui devront à ricardo
et ses tarifs uniques donc ça permet à
un maximum de personnes à assister à ces
rencontres théâtrales qui cette année
sont un peu basé sur la comédie en fait
et c'est une coïncidence la comédie où
c'est dans le choix dans la
programmation dans votre recherche
d'artistes non c'est dans le choix et la
programmation de notre recherche
d'artistes cette année vous proposer des
oeuvres très connues il ya le mariage de
figaro dès ce soir mais aussi des
oeuvres plus discrète
c'est aussi ce mix que vous avez
recherché
alors on a recherché un peu le mixte
effectivement effectivement il ya le
mariage de figaro mais il ya aussi la
cerisaie de tchekhov il ya don juan de
molière il y à une pièce de josiane
balasko
il ya un certain nombre c'est un mélange
si vous voulez qui doit permettre sur
endurance et six soirées de donner un
aspect global de la comédie
évidemment on va pas tout découvrir
on laissera pour les années c c'est la
septième année que la ville de but quand
tu aimes c'est cette ces rencontres
théâtrales dans notre théâtre et le
théâtre à terre encore aujourd'hui je
crois que le théâtre attire on a on ad
c'est pour ça qu'on veut continuer si
vous voulez a favorisé effectivement le
théâtre dans notre commune parce que je
crois que ça attire et puis on travaille
en partenariat d'une part avec la ville
de tous une homme et d'autre part avec
notre communauté d'agglomération de
versailles en parc
vous parlez de josiane balasko qui est
une grande à une grande actrice
française sur scène ce sont que des
professionnels non alors ça c'est est un
mélange en fait il ya dans dans toutes
les dents toutes les troupes qui vont se
produire durant ces six soirées
il ya des des amateurs il ya des semi
professionnels et il y à quelques
professionnels mais c'est tout ça un
ensemble n'y a pas une troupe totalement
professionnel et une troupe de
totalement amateur on disait ça commence
ce soir avec le mariage de figaro
qu'est ce qui plaît dans cette heure
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui la tient or
je crois que c'est un petit peu le le le
la pièce a intrigué à rebondissements
puisque en fait figaro veut se marier
avec une une soubrette avait avec une la
première camériste de la comtesse la
comtesse elle veut se venger de son mari
le conflit menace de s'opposer à ce
mariage si la soubrette ne cède pas à
ses avants et la voilà en une journée
folle s'arrête jamais mais c'est du bon
marché un grand auteur un grand auteur
de langue française qui a bien participé
au siècle des lumières et demain soir le
samedi c'est un peu moins connu c'est la
cerisaie de tchekhov ou paiement par là
alors ça c'est un peu moins connu
effectivement mais c'est une femme chez
colruyt dans cette oeuvre à une façon de
décrire un peu la vie
dans les provinces russes à la fin du
19e siècle en fait et c'est toute une
histoire qui tourne autour de ça je
pense que même si ça paraît si le
tchekhov globalement paraît plus rutiler
que le beau marché aux molières si vous
voulez bien sûr mais par contre c'est un
sujet intéressant et je pense que ça
peut attirer et ça attire du jeune
public même puisque on and on pense que
c'est une oeuvre qui peut être vu dès
l'âge de 10 ans on peut très bien venir
jouer là je rappelle que c'est une
comédie c'est accessible à tous les âges
vous me dire merci jean marc le rudulier
d'être venu nous parler de ces
rencontres
je vous disais ça commence ce soir mais
c'est jusqu'au dimanche 7 février
le mariage de figaro c'est le vendredi
29 janvier à 20h30 au théâtre des
arcades de buc la dernière
représentation du programme c'est tard
c'est le 7 février mais c'est au théâtre
du plessis à toussus le noble et pour le
samedi 30 janvier si vous voulez là
aussi aller au théâtre aimé découvrir la
moins connue mais non passionnante aux
pièces de la cerisaie les billets sont
disponibles sur l'adresse internet qui
s'affiche on continue avec la scène
l'humour et le rire ce week-end charles
et soignons débarque à l'estaminet de
magny les hameaux à 20h30 avec son tout
nouveau spectacle
free c'est de l'humour et du jazz on
regarde un extrait ces partis ont tourné
tout seul avec des maigres quand on ne
fait jamais commis dit john g partie
c'était genton en deux ans c'était comme
ça sanofi dont les troupes ont tourné
les mecs ont tombé ça drague d'accord et
quand il n'y arrivait pas vers 3 heures
du matin se retourner vers moi
et regardez comme ils étaient arrivés
dans primo qu'est ce que je ressentais
je te jure
desjardins c'est à dire dégueulasse que
j'ai fait
merci du riz rhodia et toujours ce
samedi là aussi à 20h30 mais c'était la
salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux vincent de diem vous propose
son one man show sephora la nama ni la
rencontre est pour nous on les écoute
avant de regarder un extrait de son
spectacle le spectacle me suis dit j'y
ai pensé comme un dîner entre amis
quand je dis dans des amis des gens à
dîner chez moi je me débrouille pour que
la cuisine soit bonne
donc là je suis débrouillé pour que le
texte soit bien écrit et je me suis
débrouillé pour que ça je me débrouille
quand les gens viennent à lison pour que
ils se marrent pour qu'on passe une
bonne soirée pourquoi les gens repartent
par exemple vivement la prochaine foire
ont su leur faire la prochaine fois ce
sétois tout ça donc
donc oui j'avais envie qu'il y ait tout
c'est tout c'est tous ces ingrédients
pour que les gens passent une bonne
soirée
le jem présent je suis sylvain que l'on
je suis acteur et metteur en scène un
metteur en scène qui effectivement
depuis quelques années a axé sa
recherche sur le souffle plus exactement
la matière souffler
que j'appelle également la voix fistules
heures c'est à dire la voix comme organe
sonic comme organe cencic et non pas
comme organe je dirais le
conversationnel si vous voulez en
découvrir un peu plus sur ce jeune
acteur de talent l'entretien est à
retrouver dans son intégralité dans le
kiosque du mercredi 20 janvier et on
passe maintenant à notre troisième et
dernière invitée qui vient nous parler
cette fois de musique conjuguer les
amateurs les musiciens plus confirmé le
classique ou encore la bande originale
de film c'est le programme du concert
symphonique que propose le conservatoire
de montigny le bretonneux et c'est
antoine boesch qui viens nous en parler
vous êtes le directeur du pôle musique
théâtre de la commune
bonjour alors le concert est en deux
parties je disais il ya des jeunes des
moins jeunes n'ait pu confirmer ça
commence avec les plus jeunes
absolument donc ça commence avec eux les
orchestres on appelle de premier cycle
c'est à dire les plus petits pour
certains c'est même leur premier concert
orchestre à cordes orchestre à vent on
aura aussi un orchestre d'harmonie et un
orchestre des élèves qui ont déjà
quelques années l'instrument c'est
l'occasion pour les élèves de montrer
leurs progrès ce qu'ils ont appris leur
savoir faire
absolument c'est même un outil de
motivation principale c'est à dire que
dans les conservatoires maintenant on
vient faire de l'instrument autant pour
avoir une pratique collective
je voulais avec les autres que de
travailler sur l'instrument tout seul ou
de jouer seul à la maison donc ses
concerts là et sont un élément premier
de motivation pour pour tous ces élèves
c'est une longue préparation pour eux
oui c'est une longue préparation il y à
des répétitions chaque semaine il ya
aussi l'instrument
on travaille aussi avec les partis qu'on
travaille avec le avec le professeur et
oui c'est un certain c'est un long
travail et sont nombreux ces élèves ils
vont jouer en général à peu près 25 par
par orchestre pour les orks des plus
petits puis après on va y venir mais
plus pour le pour l'heure quelle
symphonique puis jouer à plusieurs ça
doit pas être facile non plus alors sa
demande ça nous manque justement plein
de choses de deux d'écouté des autres de
regarder le chef de partir sur le geste
en même temps c'est une très bonne école
de l'ecoute de deux musiciens et la
deuxième partie c'est un concert
symphonique et là ils sont 50 sur scène
absolument à part comment alors là cet
orchestre symphonique et à une forme un
peu particulière puisque et c'était un
orchestre qui est ponctuelle les élèves
mélanger avec les professeurs et des
amateurs du territoire ont travaillé
pendant une semaine sous forme de
sessions genre de stage pendant une
semaine et pour donner lieu à ceux à ce
concert c'est plus ambitieux voilà ça a
plus d'envergure et on est très content
de pouvoir présenter ce programme avec
l'orchestra phonique cette envergure
parce que c'est de la symphonie
absolument par rapport aux oeuvres par
rapport au niveau des oeuvres par
rapport au nombre de musiciens
on dit toujours que voilà l'orchestré
symphonique c'est une grosse machine
quand on est dedans quand on écoute et
puis c'est voilà c'est la rolls un petit
peu de la musique et vous proposer des
oeuvres classiques alors pas que des
oeuvres classiques dont du répertoire
classique des danses de compositeurs
romantiques et aussi une pièce de
musique de film voit la musique de film
ça peut paraître un peu plus original
mais ça se prête très bien
oui absolument celle avantage de lorca
symphonique d'avoir à la fois un pile
dans le passé dans les projets les
oeuvres classiques et puis un pied dans
le
dans contemporain en entend de leur
caisse classique de l'orc est un faux
nick pardon tous les jours au cinéma
dans les plus grandes pages dont le
voilà dans les films les plus connus en
ce moment ont des pages connues
d'orchestre symphonique et cette année
vous proposer le thème de la liste de
schindler avant d'en parler je vous
propose qu'on écoute un extrait
à
lorsqu'on vient d'entendre c'est un
morceau de john williams et le thème du
film john williams ovale précisé c'est
un des compositeurs les plus célèbres en
musique de film il est notamment à
l'origine des bandes originales de star
wars et de tous les films de steven
spielberg
ce morceau là il est très fort il est
très prenant d'une grande délicatesse
mais est-ce qu'il est facile à jouer
alors non il n'est pas facile à jouer
alors donc on entendu là une version
pour piano ce qu'on va entendre et qui
réussit dans la manche finale du film
c'est donc sorte de petit concerto pour
violon un très beau thème enregistré par
itzhak perlman un des plus grands
violonistes extrêmement poignant et on a
voulu présenter cette oeuvre très belles
oeuvres peut-être un peu moins connu que
notamment les thèmes de star wars et qui
met notamment en lumière le violon une
soliste qui sera une des professeurs de
violon du conservatoire de musique mais
c'est peut-être aussi la plus douce de
tout le répertoire de john williams on
sait que star wars on sait il ya
beaucoup de d'instruments et c'est là
c'est un instrument sun qui fait toute
la force mérite absolument absolument
cesser ce qui fait vraiment la force de
cette page là
l'écriture pour le violon est absolument
magnifique et on est voilà très content
de pouvoir présenter ça et un concert
comme ça avec des amateurs ont dit c'est
le moyen de donner envie de commencer ou
de recommencer la pratique d'un
instrument absolument alors je profite
de l'occasion parce que ici des amateurs
justement sur les territoires qui ont
déjà un peu une pratique instrumentale
on vit de venir nous écouter voir de
nous rejoindre pour la prochaine session
de l'année prochaine ils sont les
bienvenus
on souhaite que ce projet dont c'est la
deuxième édition de cette session
symphonique puisse prendre de l'ampleur
et puisse être ouverte
absolument a des atouts le monde à tous
les gens qui ont envie de venir faire de
la musique qui m'ont déjà un niveau on
sait qu'on y en a pas mal sur le
territoire qui n'osent pas ressortir
leurs instruments qui m'ont fait pendant
presque parfois une dizaine d'années
donc ça peut être ce concert à
l'occasion pour des gens de venir
découvrir redécouvrir ce qui est un
orchestre symphonique ou pour des
musiciens curieux de venir écouter nous
rejoindre mais de préciser c'est la
deuxième édition ça donc plus l'an
dernier oui absolument alors l'an
dernier on était à la salle jacques brel
voilà ça eu plein de qualités la seule
chose qu'on nous a demandé c'était qu'il
puisse y avoir plus de place
donc on est très content de pouvoir
voilà avec d'avoir fait un travail avec
les élus pour pouvoir avoir la ferme du
mas mais cette année on a une salle qui
est plein ou presque
donc on voit là c'est une très bonne
chose la ferme du mas n'est pas ce que
la musique
symphonique a besoin d'amis une très
belle acoustique la ferme du mal et ça
ça va c'est une salle qui est
intéressante par son ampleur au niveau
du plateau et un grand plateau qui
laisse de la place
absolument voilà on prêt on ya un
travail intime avec les régisseurs de la
salle qui va nous permettre d'avoir le
meilleur rendu sonore possible et de
prendre plaisir
alors si vous voulez venir écouter les
musiciens découvrir de grandes pièces
classiques ou la musique la bande
originale de film c'est le dimanche 31
janvier à 15 heures à la ferme du manet
n'hésitez pas à vous laisser tenter
merci anthony veulent mais nous nous
proposer ce cette idée sortie on termine
ce magazine avec un dernier rendez vous
l'équipe du festival ciné junior de
magny les hameaux propose une
compétition de courts métrages
recherchés aux quatre coins du monde
le public est appelé à décerner son
propre prix s'étalent estaminet mercredi
3 février le 7-8 week-end est terminée
je vous remercie de nous avoir suivis je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
prouver vous proposer encore de baisse
des sorties et loisirs je vous souhaite
un excellent week-end